these strapping young men are all
members of the Polish weightlifting team
veterans of european championships and
Olympic Games this is Christian young
Kowski he's a professor of sculpture and
a conceptual artist with polish roots
based in Stuttgart his idea was to make
a film showing these muscular athletes
lifting some of Warsaw's best-known
monuments to exhibit as art
the first port of call is the landmark
serenka statue on the old town market
square the Fighting mermaid is a symbol
of Warsaw and also features on its coat
of arms she's as light as a feather no
challenge at all for nine men even four
of them can manage a mere eight hundred
kilos that was a very patriotic
experience I grew up with the warsaw
mermaid we all used to go up close and
get a good look at her we weren't
allowed to touch her but now I've not
only touched her I've actually lifted
her up she's just a monument to some
people
I've actually touched her let's hope he
realizes that this particular serenka is
only a copy concerned about vandalism
the authorities relocated the original
to the Warsaw History Museum
the rest of the day is spent looking for
more monuments in some unusual places
they tracked down Ludwig forenski
founder of the first polish worker's
party that proletariat languishing in a
garage monuments to socialists aren't
exactly well looked after
in today's poland we had to make a big
effort with lawrence ki the artist had
to motivate us because we were a bit fed
up at that point even when it was
pouring with rain he didn't lose sight
of his artistic vision it was a question
of honour we thought if we can't manage
the Socialists we're total wimps hooked
in which the whole thing was crazy
standing there in the rain with a bunch
of enthusiastic athletes 50 men in the
mud it was no picnic but it was worth it
to watch them get down to work and see
how much they believed in the idea
because they're not being paid there's
nothing in it for them they're doing it
for idealistic reasons for art it was
very moving and a beautiful thing to
behold insurances in the project goes by
the name heavyweight history an
uplifting experience for everyone
involved
that this five-ton Ronald Reagan proved
a tougher challenge than a socialist the
nads couldn't do it instead they turned
their hands to the Statue of
polish-soviet brothers and arms erected
in 1945 it's known locally as the for
sleeping soldiers perhaps because one
could argue that the Soviets didn't
actually help Warsaw resist the Nazis
one soldier alone weighs around 1.5 tons
third time lucky
Bravo yes last but not least on the list
is the villi Brunt monument in 1970 the
German Chancellor made history when he
dropped to his knees before the monument
to the Warsaw Ghetto not a chance this
is sport yeah it's like sport you don't
win every time there's no actual
opponent here so this is basically a
contest between sport and history it's
fair enough that sometimes the monuments
win the weightlifters have 15 goes at
lifting Billy blunt but eventually they
concede defeat some history is lighter
than others
you